and so it's like it's like there's  always whenever and this is just  something i've noticed in society  whenever we say a problem that men have  it's always followed up by but they do  it to themselves right or  but  men do that too like it's never just  this is a problem well that's why we're  having the show because it's like yeah  men's stuff isn't taken seriously  because like i said like i said the the  way women can weaponize their tears is  not the same men can weaponize their  teeth  if a woman ran out right now off here  crying yeah you're more likely to get  garner attention than if a man ran out  of the hair right now crap i heard this  i heard this you know what i'm saying i  heard this and i can't remember where  wow  i disagree so yeah